ses gestes
alexandre les répète plusieurs fois par
semaine en ce moment après avoir
consulté la météo il part avec le
matériel nécessaire pour une matinée de
travail par manquer son pur pour aller à
l'eau tu vois j'ai enfermé l'appareil
photo de dans là je sers tous afin que
ce soit bien du temps je pense que ce
serait dommage de perdre l'appareil est
là j'irai faire des photos d'eux sous
les vagues ou des vagues
aujourd'hui il accompagne des amis
surfeurs
mais ce sont surtout les vagues qui
l'intéressent quelques réglages sont
nécessaires et c'est parti pour des
centaines de clichés pour arriver à un
résultat optimal alexandre reste des
heures dans l'eau oui il faut être très
patient
[Musique]
des clichés surprenants plein de
fraîcheur
des moments captés sur le vif si
aujourd'hui les conditions sont plutôt
favorables
le photographe décide pas certains jours
à prendre des risques on peut très bien
venir ici et prendre vols qui ne se
passe rien du tout venir que ce sens
quasiment impossible d'atteindre
d'atteindre des vagues parce que c'est
trop c'est trop fort la mer est trop
forte
il ya toujours un coup à jouer pour
avoir de bonnes images il faut être sûr
de pouvoir rester là au ladakh casse et
c'est là que c'est un peu c'est un peu
chaud mais si on ne le fait pas on n'a
pas la bonne image
[Musique]
de retour à la maison le photographe
visionnent tous les clichés
ce matin il en a fait 983 quelques uns
seulement seront travaillés comme celle
ci la main peu n'importe comment dans
nous sépare la photo elle sort un peu
sur le côté à lui comme ça donc lancé
afin que l'horizon il soit par intérêt
soit faisons malgré une fois certaines
imperfections éliminés il peut y ajouter
de la lumière de la netteté bref la
retoucher et la sublimer
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui le motive l'amour de la
photo et les encouragements de ses
proches
le buste c'est un essai laissait plutôt
bien accueilli les gens m'encouragent à
faire plus envoyer plus donc du coup il
faut alexandre s'est inspiré d'autres
photographes elle les américains clark
little et zach noël ici son travail a
été remarqué par l'atrium mais il espère
que ces clichés inspireront les
entreprises locales pour des produits
dérivés par exemple
[Musique]
oui
m